- [Interviewer] Okay.
Your name is Rita?
Rita, where are you from originally?
- [Rita] Tucson, Arizona.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
You grow up with both of your parents?
- No, I just grew up with
my mama and she drink a lot,
havin' parties and I didn't
want to be with nobody
but my momma.
And when her died, I had
to live in a hospital.
- [Interviewer] When
did your mom pass away?
- When I was 12 years old
and I wanted to die with
her, but I couldn't.
They put me in the hospital.
But I tried to get in the casket with her
and they put me to sleep.
When I woke up, I was in the hospital.
They shoot me with some stuff
and now I gotta take it all my life.
It's Thorazine.
- [Interviewer] So, what'd you say,
you tried to get in the casket?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] With your mom?
- Yeah and I wouldn't let her go,
but they put me to sleep
and when I woke up, I was in a hospital.
It's called Palo Verde Hospital.
Palo Verde Street, Tucson, Arizona.
- [Interviewer] So, your
mom passes away at 12
and you went where?
- I went to Palo Verde
Hospital in Tucson, Arizona
and then I lived at the county hospital
at Tucson Medical Center
in the mental hospital in--
- [Interviewer] Oh, you
went to a mental hospital?
- Yeah, I lived in the ,like the exodus
and (mumbles) I don't know the other name.
I wasn't able to take care
of myself until I was 52.
I'm 57, I just turned 57 January the 13th,
and they say I'mma die
at the county hospital
in three to six weeks,
'cause they found some
black stuff in my brain.
- [Interviewer] Sorry can you repeat that?
I'm sorry.
- They found some black spots in my brain
at the county hospital on Morengo street.
- [Interviewer] And what'd they tell you?
- And they said I'mma die
from three to six weeks,
they couldn't save me but
they couldn't help me until--
- [Interviewer] So it
sounds like brain cancer?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You were in a
mental hospital for how long--
how much of your life?
- At the exodus until 2014.
- [Interviewer] So you've
been in the hospital
for most of your life.
- [Rita] Yeah until now.
They let me be on my own, but I gotta do--
get nurse and stuff
check on me all the time
right there by the forts.
The nurse comes, I gotta go see 'em
and they check on me and they
put a machine on my head.
- [Interviewer] Where
do you live right now?
- I just walk around.
- [Interviewer] You're
just out in the street?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any family?
Do you have any kids?
- [Rita] No, only me.
I'm here.
- [Interviewer] You spent your
whole life in the hospital,
so it's hard to have a family, right?
- [Rita] Yeah, I only know my sister,
but I don't know her.
I know I got a sister, but
I only stay with my momma.
My mother used to take
my sisters to her sis--
My auntie's house, and keep me with her.
- [Interviewer] And do you mess around
with any of the drugs
that are on the street?
- [Rita] Yes, when I was
prostituting I did drugs.
And then I had sex and I caught germs.
- [Interviewer] So you
started prostituting
when you came out of the hospital?
- [Rita] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] At 54,
something like that?
- No, (mumbles) yeah.
- [Interviewer] And now you just found out
you have brain cancer?
- Yeah I found out in
2018 that I had aneurysm,
I can't say it.
- [Interviewer] And what
do you do for money?
How do you survive?
- I sit on the ground sometimes
and tell 'em they could
give me food or help
or donations, so I eat leftovers.
- [Interviewer] And
then sometimes you work
as a prostitute as well?
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What's your view of life?
I mean, do you think life is just cruel?
- No, it's what we make of it,
but it's cruel to me
because I don't know nobody
I don't have no family.
- [Interviewer] Do you have any friends?
- No 'cause, I don't have friends
because I feel like I'm different.
Sometimes they say I'm
retarded or something.
I just wanna be by myself.
- [Interviewer] Have you ever had friends?
- [Rita] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] In the hospital?
- My momma's friends, I
had my momma's friends.
- [Interviewer] Oh okay.
Well Rita thank you so much
for sharing you story.
It's a tragedy.
- It's not a story, it's for real.
- [Interviewer] I know it's real.